emergency services in the Bahamas
continue to sift through the debris left
in the wake of Hurricane durian search
and rescue crews have arrived from the
u.s. in Canada to locate the thousands
who are listed as missing the number of
that is expected to significantly
increase the grief little bear as a
country begins with the families who
have lost loved ones the islands of
Abaco and Grand Bahama were the worst
hit the devastation here is widespread
our sample I would say yes you know
we've we've probably hit at most one
tenth of this area and we so far we have
we found five human remains I would say
based off of our sample size we're gonna
see more in the community of marsh
Harbor entire neighborhoods were wiped
off the map and the debris scattered by
Dorian's destructive winds and storm
surge have left behind a challenging
environment for search and recovery
workers many are relying on assistance
from search dogs to help locate bodies
hidden beneath the mountains of rubble
the challenges for this operation have
been immense we have not seen anything
like a debris field like this areas that
are impassable there are multiple
hazards here like nails corrugated steel
glass you know things like that the
Bahamian government says about 5,000
people have been evacuated from the
worst affected areas most have been sent
to shelters in the capital city of
Nassau what we're seeing is a lot of
families that are wondering whether
their loved ones are and it's going to
take time for the authorities to to
identify the the missing and learn more
about the what may end up being a really
tragic death toll
the World Health Organization says an
estimated 70,000 people have been left
without shelter making hurricane durian
the worst natural disaster in the
nation's history monopoly josita